so
you too need a little help the overall
premise
of false positive is about this white
well-to-do new york city couple who
has been trying for a long time to get
pregnant
and they embark on this pregnancy
journey
you are 100 pregnant
we are specifically exploring the
horrors that come up in this world
it really is a scary experience
from the inside out this film is not
necessarily a genre film
it's a psychological satire
i wanted to create a woman who assumed
that her
life was more empowered than it really
was
am i going to be one of those women who
has it all
my career or my kids my old man by my
side who are you calling old
lucy to me is an instagram liberal
you know like someone who has a lot of
privilege
and slowly wakes up to a reality that
she's been kind of pushed into
that she didn't need to participate in
i'm having the wildest mommy brain
lately
i'm not crazy they're trying to make me
think i'm crazy
the frame we're widening out to
in reviewing the power structures that
run this world
are a lot there's a lot of voodoo out
there
we just want to make sure that you get
the best possible care
if you just think about what a woman
goes through when she becomes pregnant
she has to make a choice
do i want to have children or not do i
give up work or not
am i a mom or an employee they all fit
under this larger umbrella of
misogyny the way that our society works
makes pregnant people
the most vulnerable hey
this pregnancy [ __ ] is no joke right
damn pregnancy and horror does go
together very well